christmas has come early for the super
rich supercar fan because Lamborghini
has just come out with this brand new
Aventador super veloce it costs five
hundred thousand dollars and it has 750
horsepower we're going to test it out at
this world famous formula 1 track
Barcelona Catalunya
Oh in the Rings
steering like the red
horse and may
so exciting
we drinkin the Lamborghini on the track
now we're testing it out on the back
roads of Barcelona to see what's like in
the country maybe even an urban setting
already I'm noticing that the gearbox
cannot decide what to do shifting back
and forth looking for the right here at
low speeds this automatic gearbox is not
terribly happy zone has shifted into a
manual mode and do the work myself a
number of other things that Lamborghini
has improved upon for the super veloce
includes the steering what they call
lamborghini dynamic steering is a system
they've developed to allow easier
turning of the wheel at lower speeds and
more stability at high speeds as well
those were some of the most insane roads
I've ever driven and the car is I would
say it's perfect because of the power
and the lightness but it's huge so forth
in tight roads like this it can be a
little bit hairy a little bit scary and
that's not necessarily bad to be honest
I kind of like to be scared let's take
it back to the track that's where this
beast really belong
real unreal
you